hey guys P here this is my top moments
of Twin Peaks season 3 part 8 if you
haven't watch part 8 yet this is your
spoiler warning go back and watch some
of my other videos for one of the
episodes you've seen because this will
definitely spoil it for you
alright so this was an amazing episode
for me personally I can see that some
people might not have enjoyed what
happened in the last 40 minutes but I
think on the initial watch I came away
with the idea that we actually learned a
lot but I'm not gonna get into any of
that really here because I want to go
back and look at things a little more
closely so I'm just going to talk about
the top moments as they were for me the
first one was evil coop getting shot I
did not see this coming
I figured that rave would give up the
information and that would be that but
he double-crossed him
tricked him and shot him like mostly but
I've never really thought that evil
Cooper would die right there but I have
to admit that I did not envision what
happened in the next moment which was
the guys who were painted black swarming
the scene way this was delivered was
awesome how they were sort of in the
flickering light and I pretty much felt
like Ray did watching it all go down the
next big moment was that Ray actually
called Hill Jeffries on the road we saw
that evil coupe had set things up so
that they were free to travel we know
he's headed to some place called the
farm and apparently he is still working
with Jeffries because he's got him on
speed dial
the next big moment required a trip back
in time and the nuclear explosion is
what I'm talking about this was probably
one of my favorite things that I've ever
saw on television the entirety of the
music and the visuals the sort of visual
ride we took when we entered the
mushroom cloud through space and time
then we saw the giant at home and we met
his roommate now this is something that
is going to take a lot more of an
investment of time to describe this
theme properly but we see him he gets
alerted by the Bell thing that's
in one of the rooms and then he goes
upstairs watches on a screen what's
going on which is this nuclear explosion
he witnesses the next big moment that we
had witnessed fryer which was what looks
like Bob's origin scene now I'm not sure
if this is when bob was created or if
this is when bob was unleashed into the
world we'll talk about that in another
video but for now it was pretty visually
interesting and we could tell by the
look on the giant space that it was also
very important to the balance of
everything inside this universe the next
big moment was when the giant started to
float we saw some golden light come out
of him and then we saw the birth of this
golden or as it comes down to his
roommate who's there on the floor I'm
calling her roommate right now because
what else do we know about her she peers
into the orb and we see Laura Palmer's
face so what happened here well it looks
like this couple of people the Giant and
his friend had given birth to Laura
Palmer in response to Bob entering into
the world she uses this device that they
have and sends it off into the world and
that's all I'm really going to say about
that right now
another big moment was obviously during
that explosion we saw a convenience
store which is definitely something
that's important inside this mythology
if you remember Phil Jeffries told
Gordon that he attended one of their
meetings that was held above the
convenience store and here again we see
a ton of these guys with the faces that
are painted black sort of swarming
around this convenience store my initial
guess when watching was that this is the
same thing they were unleashed into the
world and because of this nuclear
explosion that's what it kind of looks
like visually to me anyways I don't
think that this explosion will be the
genesis of everything that happens you
know the genesis of the lodge's
necessarily because obviously the giant
was already
there but it is interesting to be able
to connect these figures to the ones
that we've seen show up in South Dakota
the next big moment was meeting the
woodsman at least that's what he's
credited as in the credits and we've
seen that name before this was what a
lot of people thought a guy in the jail
cell was was the woodsman from above the
convenience store so we see how that all
ties them together he delivered one of
the best lines of the season so far when
he goes around holding a cigarette and
ass everyone got a light
got a light no one seems to be able to
produce one although it's not clear if
they're just like in some kind of a
spell by just seeing him or whatever but
he does go the entirety of the episode
without ever getting his cigarette lid
the next big moment for me was the
tension that I felt when these two kids
are walking around trying to figure out
who they might be and expecting one of
them to say the other person's name so
we kick it at him I mean I was totally
like wow I can't be Leland and it can't
be Starks era they're not from that area
you know going through all these
different checklists in my head of who
these people could be and of course we
get a really tender moment between them
when they have their first kiss but we
don't have any idea who they are based
on what we saw the next big moment was
at the radio station where the woodsman
came in killed the receptionist by
touching her head for her extended
period of time and then takes over the
job of disk jockey and starts
broadcasting what I guess you would call
a poem he repeats over and over that
this is the water and this is the well
drink full and descend the horse is the
white of the eyes and dark within so the
next thing that starts to happen as we
see all these people in the town in
broadcasting range I guess who are
listening to the radio start falling
asleep this includes the young girl that
we saw get the goodnight kiss and this
leads to our next big moment which is
this creature that had hatched from the
egg that sort of looks like a cross
between
I don't know a frog a rabbit and a bug
something like that travels to her house
and crawls into her mouth so those were
my top moments whatever yours I want to
know please leave them in the comments I
will be starting my scene by scene
breakdown recap and review after this
like I said my initial reaction to this
is that they gave us a lot of answers
but there's some details that you really
need to take a closer look at I suppose
I mean I don't I'm not saying that I
have the answers to everything that's
going on or anything like that but I
think as far out as this episode seemed
it was pretty there was a good bit of
storytelling there and that was my
initial reaction so tell me what you
think I think this will probably be an
episode that people will love but it may
also be the episode that drives some
people completely away I mean I think
the visuals were just amazing I think
the sound and the songs you know
everything all the music was perfect
there was a ton of tension throughout
the scenes with the Giant and I don't
know we'll call her mother the giant and
the mother there was tons of tension in
the scenes with the kids as he's walking
her home I don't know I was just
basically on the edge of my seat the
entire time but I'm interested to see
what you guys think as well please like
the video if you enjoyed it join the
conversation in the comments be sure to
subscribe to my channel because now that
we have a two-week break until the next
episode I'm definitely going to try to
catch up on some Theory videos and
different things as soon as I do the
recap and review which will be followed
by the 10 things you might have missed
all right thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon